David Boder: [In English] Taken at a Home... for adult...
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Wie heißt diese Strasse? Rue de?
Jola Gross: Rue de Patin.
David Boder: [In English] Rue Patin. On Rue Neuf... Number 9 Rue Patin. There are mostly elderly or grown up people, who have been in various concentration camps and are now waiting for... to go either to Palestine or to the United States. Most of them cannot work, they are not French citizens and have no opportunity to do some work.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Also sagen Sie mir — again - wieder, was ist Ihr Name? Sie sagen Frau Gross?
Jola Gross: Ja, Gross, Fräulein Gross.
David Boder: Und was ist Ihr erster Name, Fräulein Gross?
Jola Gross: Yetta.
David Boder: Was?
Jola Gross: Jola.
David Boder: Ihr Name, Ihr erster Name ist Jola? Genau
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie alt sind Sie, Fräulein Gross?
Jola Gross: Wie alt? Sechsunddreißig (36) Jahre.
David Boder: Sie sind sechsunddreißig (36) Jahre alt?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie geboren?
Jola Gross: In Czyni Verezky.
David Boder: In Czyni Verezky? Wo ist Czyni Verezky?
Jola Gross: Das ist ... das ist ....hm, ...in den Karpaten.
David Boder: Ja. Das ist in die Karpaten?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Was war das? Tschechoslowakei?
Jola Gross: Tschechoslowakei
David Boder: Das war also Tschechoslowakei.
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, Fräulein Gross, wo waren Sie wie der Krieg angefangen hat und was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
Jola Gross: Zur Zeit, hm, waren es Ungarn da.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Die haben sich auch nicht gut benommen.
David Boder: Ja. (Pause) Ja, gehen Sie weiter — nun?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Und? Dann ....
Jola Gross: Dann hat man uns ... in 44 werden wir — ja, da hat man uns deportiert.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie warten. Wann hat der Krieg bei Ihnen angefangen?
Jola Gross: Hm, also ... im 39’er Jahr.
David Boder: Der Krieg hat angefangen im 39’er Jahr? Und was hat Ihnen dann passiert?
Jola Gross: Wir sind ... wir waren noch zu Hause, das schwere Leben und das ist nicht mehr so, wie wir es gehabt haben.
David Boder: Ja, und alles ist so gegangen bis wann?
Jola Gross: Bis zum 44’er Jahr.
David Boder: Bis zum vier ...
Jola Gross: Dann hat man .... man uns nach Auschwitz deportiert.
David Boder: Ja, also erzählen Sie mir, was hat passiert bevor man Sie nach Auschwitz deportiert?
Jola Gross: Man hat zusammen genommen alle, die ganze Familie und man hat uns in ein Sammellager geführt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Dort waren wir 4 Wochen im Sammellager. Dann hat man uns deportiert nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Aha, Also Sie sind sicher?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir, Fräulein Gross, Sie haben ein Tattoo aus Ihrem Arm?
David Boder: Was ist das?
Jola Gross: Sieben tausend sieben hundert acht und sechzig (7768).
David Boder: [In English] She carries a tattoo A dash seven thousand seven hundred sixty five — ah, sixty eight (A-7768).
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Verschwindet das Tattoo?
Jola Gross: Nein.
David Boder: Es kann nicht verschwinden?
David Boder: Wo hat man Sie tätowiert?
Jola Gross: In Auschwitz.
David Boder: Oh, man hat sie erst .... Also wir noch einmal vom Beginn. Sie waren in einem Sammellager.
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Vier Wochen ... und dann, wie haben Sie dort gelebt in dem Sammellager?
Jola Gross: Im Sammellager, na, da haben wir auch schwer gelebt. Wir haben jeden Tag, die SS Männer haben uns geschlagen und auch Einen tot geschlagen. Wir waren dort 4 Wochen, dann hat man uns zusammen genommen — drei tausend (3.000) — und man hat uns einwagoniert. Vier und achtzig (84) Personen waren wir in einem Wagon und man hat uns weiter deportiert.
David Boder: Also, jetzt wollen wir mal warten. Also nach Auschwitz hat man genommen die Männer und die Frauen?
Jola Gross: Rechts.
David Boder: Was ist recht?
Jola Gross: Rechts die Männer und die Frauen.
David Boder: Erst die Männer und die Frauen?
Jola Gross: Ja, genau.
David Boder: Und was hat man getan mit die Kinder?
Jola Gross: Das war so. Wir sind nah Auschwitz gekommen und
David Boder: Also zuerst nach dem Sammellager?
Jola Gross: In Sammellager sind wir zusammen.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Frauen, Kinder, Eltern - alle zusammen waren wir. Auch im Wagon waren wir auch zusammen. Man hat uns alle zusammen genommen in diesen Wagon.
David Boder: Ja. Nun ja, in Auschwitz haben Sie gelebt in einem Block, in Barracken?
Jola Gross: In Auschwitz sind wir .....
David Boder: Nein, nein, nein, in dem ..... entschuldigen Sie bitte. In den anderen Lager, in dem Sammellager — wie haben Sie dort gelebt?
Jola Gross: Im ersten Lager wo ....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: In dem Sammellager?
David Boder: Ja! Wie haben Sie dort gelebt?
Jola Gross: Ja, wir haben gelebt, .... erst hat man in der Stadt die Demokraten hat man .... noch diese Leute nicht genommen
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Sie haben uns herein geschickt etwas Essen, ja.
David Boder: Oh die Juden haben herein geschickt das Essen.
Jola Gross: Die Juden haben reingeschickt das Essen.
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Wo war das Sammellager?
Jola Gross: In Munkacz.
David Boder: In Munkacz?
David Boder: Munkacz. Und haben Sie im Sammellager gearbeitet?
Jola Gross: Nein, nein, das haben wir nicht.
David Boder: Und wir haben Sie geschlafen? Apart von den (unverständlich)?
Jola Gross: Auf die Erde.
David Boder: Ja, aber apart von den Frauen und apart von die Männer?
Jola Gross: Nein, da haben Familien zusammen geschlafen.
David Boder: Familien sind zusammen geblieben mit die Kinder?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Ja! Und was haben Sie den ganzen Tag getan?
Jola Gross: Was hat man getan? Die Männer sind gegangen arbeiten, eben welche Arbeit man hat, aber es waren ja nur vier (4) Wochen.
David Boder: Ja, hm.
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Ja und wen hat man geschlagen und wen hat man da tot geschlagen?
Jola Gross: Einen Juden.
David Boder: Einen Juden und warum hat man ihn tot geschlagen?
Jola Gross: Weil er am Morgen auf ist von, von den Barracken und — weil man hat nicht gewusst, wer er ist und man hat ihn tot geschlagen.
David Boder: Was hat man — hat man ihn erschossen?
Jola Gross: Ja, erschossen.
David Boder: Und nun gehen Sie weiter.
Jola Gross: Hm.
David Boder: Und dann hat man Sie einwagoniert?
Jola Gross: Einwagoniert .....
David Boder: Einwagoniert — die Familien zusammen?
Jola Gross: Ja, Familien zusammen — das war am 15. Mai im 44’er Jahr.
David Boder: Ja! Und?
Jola Gross: Und man hat uns .... wir sind am 18. Mai nach, nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Wie lange hat diese Reise gedauert?
Jola Gross: Vom Fünfzehnten bis ...
David Boder: ... bis zum 18. Mai .....
Jola Gross: Ja
David Boder: ... sind Sie unterwegs gewesen. Hat man Sie gefüttert — Ihnen gegeben zu Essen?
Jola Gross: Nein, nein. Wir haben sich’s mit genommen.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Wir haben sich Essen genommen und Wasser haben wir sehr wenig gekriegt. Auch am Frühmorgen hab ich gesagt wir bitten um Wasser ....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: ....und durch das Fenster sagte man, „Ihr werdet gleich ausgeladen”.
David Boder: Ja. Was war da? Ein Fenster im Wagon?
Jola Gross: Hm, ja, durch so ein kleines Fenster wir waren ....
David Boder: War das ein Passagierwagon?
Jola Gross: Ja, ein Passagierwagon — 84 waren wir.
David Boder: War da eine Toilette in dem Wagon?
Jola Gross: Nein.
David Boder: Nein, so wie sind die Leute ......
Jola Gross: Sehr schwer. Für die Kinder war es sehr schwer. Wir haben sie durch die Fenster geschieben.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: ... in so ein Ding ... wir haben es durch das Fenster geschoben ...
Jola Gross: sehr schwer ... so ein Kübel ....(flüstert)
David Boder: Ja und nun?
Jola Gross: Dann hat man uns am Achtzehnten früh morgens ausgeladen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Wir haben nicht gewusst, wo wir sind. Dann zwischen 2 Wagonen sind wir stehen geblieben und SS davor
Jola Gross: und da haben die gestreiften Männer .....
David Boder: Wer sind gestreifte Männer?
Jola Gross: Das waren schon die Häftlinge.
David Boder: Häftlinge?
Jola Gross: Ja, die Juden-Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Und die haben gesagt „Ihr lasst Eure Pakete und kommt hier runter.” Und wir haben gesagt „was, was wird hier sein” „Aber fragt nicht und lasst Eure Pakete, Ihr braucht kein Paket.” Und man hat uns runter genommen . Wir sagen: „Weißt Du nicht, was wird man hier mit uns machen?” Sagt der Herr, der Häftling sagt: „Oi weh, was wird man hier mit Euch machen.” Sagt eine Frau dann: „Sag mir, können wir sagen (unverständlich) Israel” Sagt dann” Oh je, ich hab meine Frau und Kinder auch hier gelassen.” (flüstert dann) und dann haben die Leute zu weinen angefangen.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter. Die Leute haben angefangen zu weinen?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Also — gehen Sie weiter.
Jola Gross: Und dann haben sie gesagt — rechts sollen gehen die Männer und extra dann die Frauen in 5’er Reihen. Dann haben wir fünfer Reihen gemacht und wir sind extra gegangen. Am Ende von dem Wagon ... am Zugende da stehen zwei oder drei SS Männer und Einer war dazwischen ... Dr. Mengele.
David Boder: Wer war der Doktor?
Jola Gross: Dr. Mengele
David Boder: Ein Deutscher?
Jola Gross: Ein deutscher SS Mann.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Und er hat gesagt: „Einer wird hier her gehen rechts und der Andere soll links gehen.”
Jola Gross: Wir haben nichts gewusst, was es dabei geht. Aber es links hier hat er Einige geschickt und das zweite Seite Einige .....
David Boder: Ja, hm.
Jola Gross: .... hat er geschickt. Und wir sind gekommen weiter.
David Boder: Und wo sind die Kinder geblieben?
Jola Gross: Auch sind sie geblieben mit den Anderen, mit der Mutter.
David Boder: Die Kinder sind gegangen mit wem?
Jola Gross: Mit wem, mit der Mutter. Die Schwachen und die Alten ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... sind links gegangen. Die Arbeitskraft sind rechts gegangen und wir sind weiter.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie gegangen?
Jola Gross: Rechts.
David Boder: Rechts — warum?
Jola Gross: Weil sie Arbeitskraft in mir gesehen habe.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: (schreit) „Jetzt rechts, weg!”
David Boder: Nun — also sind Sie gegangen rechts. Also wie hat das passiert?
Jola Gross: Wir sind gegangen und dann sind wir ins Bad.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Das ist gestanden „Desinfizierung” überall, auf den Stiegen (unverständlich) Desinfektion. Wir kommen in das Bad im Hof, dort hinein ... haben wir nicht alle auf einmal können baden. Damals war es ein sechstausend (6.000) Transport. Es waren von Kassel dreitausend deportiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Und wir sind dort hin gekommen und man hat 50, 60 auf einmal in diese Räume rein gelassen und wir sind draußen noch gestanden. Wie wir sind draußen gestanden, sehen wir diese, die nach links gegangen sind, sind weiter und wir sehen sie durch die Bäume, sie gehen zwischen die Bäume und mit die Kinder, Mutter und die Schwestern und die Alten alle mit die Kinder und sie gehen. Und wir haben geglaubt die kommen auch zu uns. Dann aber haben wir gehört sehr viel Weinen und Schreien. Wir haben auch sehr ....... (Lärm) ... wir haben auch sehr angefangen zu weinen und zu schreien und gefragt, was das ist wohl — warum die weinen. Da war erst eine Frau und die hat gesagt: „Alle herein in die Sauna” und da sind wir alle hinein. Und mehr haben wir nicht gehört, was mit den Anderen passiert hat.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jola Gross: Dann — danach hatten .... wir sind im Freien und in das Bad hinein gegangen und dann hat man alles aus... wir haben sich ausgezogen, die Kleider und alles. Und man hat die Haare abgeschnitten und wir sind so ....
David Boder: Wer hat das getan? Männer oder Frauen?
Jola Gross: Auf Männer und Frauen.
David Boder: Ja. Haben sie ihnen die Haare abgeschnitten?
Jola Gross: Abgeschnitten. Ja und dann sind wir auf die reine Seite hinaus gegangen.
David Boder: Und wo hat man Ihnen die Haare abgeschnitten?
Jola Gross: Überall.
David Boder: Den Kopf auch?
Jola Gross: Den Kopf auch.
David Boder: Den Kopf und den Körper?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Und wer hat das getan? Männer und ...?
Jola Gross: Männer und Frauen auch.
David Boder: Was für ... womit haben sie die Haare abgeschnitten.
Jola Gross: Mit Schere und .... mit den Dinge, hm, auch mit, hm, wie heißt das?
David Boder: Elektrische ....
Jola Gross: Nein, nein.
David Boder: Mit Messer?
Jola Gross: Nein.
David Boder: Rasiermesser?
Jola Gross: Nein, nein. Mit, mit Maschine ....
David Boder: Ja, mit Maschine!
Jola Gross: Mit Maschine und mit ......
David Boder: Schere.
Jola Gross: ... und mit Schere. Ja. Und dann haben sich alle gebadet und wir sind auf der reinen Seite raus. Wir haben andere Kleider, ah, Kleider bekommen und sind wieder raus und man hat uns geführt ins Block hinein.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Wir waren in dem Block dreizehn hundert (1.300) Leute ... in einem Block.
David Boder: Nur Frauen?
Jola Gross: Nur Frauen. Das war im Frauen Konzentrationslager .... FKF.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, wo war Ihre Familie? Wer von Ihrer Familie?
Jola Gross: Von meiner ....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Einen Bruder hab ich gehabt ....
Jola Gross: ... und eine Schwester, die Schwester und die Kinder sind hin. Der Bruder war auch bei der Arbeit ....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: .... weil im Bad haben wir die Beiden gesehen. Aber die Schwester und die Kinder sind weg nach rechts und sind verbrennt.
David Boder: Ja, ...... ja.
Jola Gross: Und dann sind wir in den Block hinein — dort waren wir dreizehn hundert in einem Block. Na, das hab ich schon gesagt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Und wir haben auf einem Bett zu zwölft geschlafen.
David Boder: Was heißt es ‚in einem Bett’?
Jola Gross: So — es war ein so gross .... zwei Betten waren dort, aber nicht solche Betten, wie bei uns ....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: ..... so in der Wand war das ... die, diese Betten.
David Boder: Ja, solche ... solche Klappbetten?
Jola Gross: Ja, Klappbetten .... so in der Wand ... und dort sind wir zwölf in einem Bett.
David Boder: Geschlafen?
Jola Gross: Ja, geschlafen
David Boder: Ja und?
Jola Gross: Ja und da haben wir auch Suppe bekommen und zwanzig oder fünfundzwanzig Deka Brot jeden Tag.
David Boder: Ja
Jola Gross: Und dort waren wir 6 Wochen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Nach die 6 Wochen ......
David Boder: Haben Sie gearbeitet?
Jola Gross: Nein, nein.
David Boder: Nein.
Jola Gross: Wir haben nicht gearbeitet, nur in der Früh aufgestanden um drei Uhr und wir sind gestanden beim Zähl-Appell.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Das hat gedauert bis acht Uhr .....
Jola Gross: .... in der Früh und dann sind wir draußen gelegen den ganzen Tag.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Und nach sechs Wochen hat man wieder Zähl-Appell gemacht ....
David Boder: Hm.
Jola Gross: .... so einen Besonderen und man hat gewählt wieder zum tätowieren. Also die Schwachen hat man wieder rausgenommen und die Stärkeren hat man tätowiert und man hat geschickt in Arbeitslager ....in, in „B”. Wir waren im „A” und jetzt ... dann sind wir nach „B” ins Lager.
David Boder: Wie hat man Sie tätowiert?
Jola Gross: In „A” — das ist Bad.
David Boder: Im Bad?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Wie haben sie das getan?
Jola Gross: Mit einem .... hm, mit .... mit einem Ding.
David Boder: Mit einer Nadel?
Jola Gross: Nein, mit einer Feder.
David Boder: Feder.
Jola Gross: Feder.
David Boder: Und wieso ist die Feder so tief reingegangen?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Es hat weh getan.
Jola Gross: Und dann ......
David Boder: Und wer hat das gemacht? Häftlinge?
Jola Gross: Häftlinge, Ja.
David Boder: Jüdische Haeftlinge?
Jola Gross: Jüdische Häftlinge, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann sind Sie in Lager „B” gegangen?
Jola Gross: Im Lager „B”, dort haben wir gearbeitet, da hab ich gearbeitet — im Außen Kommando.
David Boder: Was war das?
Jola Gross: Das war Feldarbeit, Bauarbeit und
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: ..... noch Ähnliches. Solche was sie brauchten immer die Arbeiter.
David Boder: Bauarbeit?
Jola Gross: Ja, Bauarbeit.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gebaut? Ein Haus?
Jola Gross: Wir haben .... hm, Häuser genommen und die Ziegel ... und die, diese getragen und bei dem Bau auch dasselbe ...
David Boder: Was für Häuser haben Sie zernommen?
Jola Gross: Alte Häuser haben wir zernommen und auch Neue, ich weiß nicht wir haben das außen von dem Draht gemacht und Arbeiten.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Wir haben das gemacht und dann haben wir einen Wald gepflanzt ....
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jola Gross: ...und auch ausgerottet teils .....
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Das war auch sehr schwer ... die Arbeit!
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das getan?
Jola Gross: In Birkenau.
David Boder: Ist Birkenau near Auschwitz?
Jola Gross: Birkenau, das ist das größte Lager von .... von ...
David Boder: Auschwitz?
Jola Gross: Von Auschwitz.
David Boder: Hm.
Jola Gross: Es war ein vierzig Quadratkilometer (40 km2) großes Lager.
David Boder: Nun?
Jola Gross: Nun sind wir jeden Tag dorthin gegangen zum Arbeiten. Und Musik hat gespielt.
David Boder: Was für eine Musik haben sie gehabt? Erzählen Sie mir mehr darüber.
Jola Gross: Musikanten ... von Häftlingen ....
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen
Jola Gross: Bei die Männer waren Männer, bei die Frauen waren Frauen.
David Boder: Waren da Frauen, die spielen konnten?
Jola Gross: Die Frauen, die spielen konnten, war, war bei, bei dem Tor, wie wir sind hinaus gegangen. Sie sind gewesen auf dem Musikplatz, die Musik hat .....
David Boder: Was haben die Frauen gespielt?
Jola Gross: Die haben gespielt nur einen Marsch, weil wir so können links treten, weil wir haben nur können links treten und so sind wir weg und wir sind acht Kilometer oder 10 Kilometer zu Fuß zu der Arbeit.
David Boder: Und die Musik ist mitgegangen?
Jola Gross: Nein, die sind dann nur ... haben begleitet am Tor.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Und wenn wir wiederkommen .....
Jola Gross: ... sind sie auch gesessen beim Tor und haben gespielt.
David Boder: Warten Sie mal! Und was für Instrumente haben sie gespielt? Sie sagen es wären Frauen gewesen.
Jola Gross: Mit Klavier .... nicht mit ... mit Violinen.
David Boder: Violinen?
Jola Gross: Violinen.
David Boder: Und mit Trompeten?
Jola Gross: Und es war eine Kapellmeisterin.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Alles Häftlinge.
David Boder: Und nur?
Jola Gross: Am Abend sind wir, wie wir nach Hause gekommen, haben wir wieder gekriegt das Brot .....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... und .... hm, zum Schlafen gelegen.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Wieder ein Tag weniger.
Jola Gross: Einmal sind wir von die Arbeit gegangen, haben wir die.. ein Auto. Da haben wir gesehen von Weitem, das Auto - es wird schon — es war schon Nacht - 5 Monate, sechs Monate nach dem Kommen nach Birkenau — haben wir gesehen ein Auto fahren. Wir sind durchgegangen, wo die zwei Krematorien sind und wir haben gehört ungarisch, wie ein Mädel schreit: „Führt uns nicht ins Krematorium, wir sind noch jung, wir wollen leben.” Und man hat sie in Krematorium geführt vom Revier.
David Boder: Von wo?
Jola Gross: Vom Revier.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Jola Gross: Revier heißt, hm, ein Krankenaus.
David Boder: Oh, ein Kranken.......
Jola Gross: Ja, Revier, das hat so geheißen. Und vom Revier .... vom Revier hat man vor Abend vor dem Zähl-Appell — da hat man die weggenommen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jola Gross: Wer hat schlecht ausgeschaut, hat man jede Woche oder jede zwei Wochen war eine Selektion.
David Boder: Hm.
Jola Gross: Das heißt eine, die werden ....
David Boder: Ja, ich verstehe
Jola Gross: ... eine Selektion. Man hat aufgeschrieben die Namen, die, wie sie .... die Tätowier-Nummer und man hat sie weg geführt, die, die haben schlecht ausgeschaut.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Und ich habe einen Bruder geahbt5, der .... bei Sonderkommando hat der gearbeitet.
David Boder: Was ist ein Sonderkommando?
Jola Gross: Ein Sonderkommando ist, wie der hat gearbeitet beim Brennen der Menschen, die man hat verbrannt.
David Boder: Und Ihr Bruder hat dort gearbeitet?
Jola Gross: Hat dort auch gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Hat er mir geschrieben einmal einen kleinen Zettel, dass er arbeitet dort und dort und er hofft, er wird noch heraus kommen, aber leider ...man hat ihn im September hat man ihn verbrennt.
David Boder: Wie und warum?
Jola Gross: Man hat rausgenommen von dort zwei hundert.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Und man hat sie einwagoniert in die Wagonen ....
Jola Gross: Das heißt man hat sie auf Transport geschickt ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... und man hat sie weggeschickt von Birkenau bis nach Auschwitz. In den Wagonen hat man sie vergast und zurück gebringt ins Krematorium zum Verbrennen.
David Boder: Oh, man hat sie vergast in den Wagonen?
Jola Gross: In die Wagonen.
David Boder: Warum?
Jola Gross: Dies hat man speziell behandelt, weil die haben gewusst, was sie gemacht haben mit die anderen tausend Leut.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Da hat man mit diesen anders gemacht.
Jola Gross: Man hat sie weggeschickt; das hat geheißen ein Transport.
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Die sind dann im Transport von dort weg von Birkenau und man hat sie in den Wagonen ...
David Boder: Vergast.
Jola Gross: ... vergast und man hat sie ....
David Boder: Zurück gebracht.
Jola Gross: ... zurück gebracht und verbrennt.
David Boder: Nun und Ihr Bruder war darunter?
Jola Gross: War da.
David Boder: Wieso hatten Sie das erfahren?
Jola Gross: Die Alten sind geblieben von diesen .... da haben acht hundert Männer gearbeitet bei dem Sonderkommando. Es sind ein paar Polnische geblieben und im ..... hm, im Septemb .... im November ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: ... und im November hat man die Krematorien zernommen.
David Boder: Warum?
Jola Gross: Weil man hat nicht wollen, .... weil man hat gewusst, das ist schon .... kommen die, die Russen schon und die sollen nicht sehen ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: ... was dort, was man da gemacht hat. Da hat man das ... da hab ich dann gearbeitet.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie gearbeitet? Bei den Krematorien?
Jola Gross: Bei den Krematorien, denn man hat das ... hm, aus ....
David Boder: Auseinander genommen.
Jola Gross: .... auseinander genommen. Und dort die Männer, die noch sind geblieben, haben sie mir erzählt, wie es war damals.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Damals und dass mein Bruder dabei war damals auch dabei.
David Boder: Und nachdem die Krematorien auseinander genommen waren ....
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Wurden Leute immer noch vergast?
Jola Gross: Nein. Im Aug ..... Ende November hat man schon nicht mehr .... hm,..... hm, hat man schon nicht mehr gebrennt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Man hat sie alle ... es waren vier Krematorien, man hat das .... nur Eines ist geblieben um die Toten zu verbrennen.
David Boder: Ja, nun? Was ist dann passiert?
Jola Gross: Was .... was noch?
David Boder: Was ist dann danach passiert? Wieso sind Sie befreit worden?
Jola Gross: Ich bin befreit worden, weil ich bin in dem fünfzehnten Jänner bin ich ins Transport gegangen nach Sudeten Deutschland, in Fabrik ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... zu arbeiten.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das? In welchem Jahr war das?
Jola Gross: Im ......
David Boder: 45.
Jola Gross: .... im 45’er Jahr.
David Boder: Ja.?
Jola Gross: Bin ich hin gegangen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Jola Gross: Und dort bin ich gewesen bis man hat uns evakuiert von dort. Dann sind wir evakuiert ohne Essen und ... und ich bin ....
David Boder: Wohin?
Jola Gross: Nach .... weiter in Deutschland und ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... und ich bin zurück geblieben.
David Boder: In den Sudeten?
Jola Gross: Ja, weil ich hab nicht wollen weiter gehen. Ich hab .... bin sehr krank gewesen und hab geschwollene Füss gehabt und ich bin zurück geblieben. Und dann sind gekommen der Russen.
David Boder: Hm.
Jola Gross: Und wir sind befreit geworden.
David Boder: Sie sind befreit geworden?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: So — wie sind Sie dann nach Paris gekommen?
Jola Gross: Nach Paris bin ich .... ich bin nach Deutschland. Dort war ich ....
David Boder: Wie? Die Russen haben Sie befreit wo? In den Sudenten?
Jola Gross: In den Sudeten.
David Boder: Alright! So wie sind Sie von den Sudeten weg gekommen?
Jola Gross: Da bin ich nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Warum.
Jola Gross: Weil ich weg ... ich will nicht mehr sein , wo man hat meine Angehörigen schon geschlachtet und wo ist ihr Blut. Weil ich will nach Palästina fahren.
David Boder: Haben die Russen Ihnen erlaubt weg zugehen oder sind sie weg gelaufen?
Jola Gross: Nein, wir sind ja frei und in der Gruppe und wir fahren, nein wir sind auf Reisende.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Im Mai sind wir nach Prag. Dann sind wir nach .....
David Boder: Dann sind Sie nach Deutschland gegangen.
Jola Gross: Nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Und von Deutschland?
Jola Gross: Von Deutschland bin ich nach Paris, weil ich will nach Palästina
David Boder: Frei .... und sie sind frei gefahren?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie Geld gehabt?
Jola Gross: Nein.
David Boder: So wie sind Sie gefahren?
Jola Gross: Ohne Geld!
David Boder: Alright. Und warum .... Sie sind sechsunddreißig Jahre alt?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Warum Sie immer schon eine Zionistin, eine Zionistin?
David Boder: Und was wollen Sie in Palästina tun?
Jola Gross: Arbeiten.
David Boder: Hm?
Jola Gross: Ich will nicht mehr bleiben in solche Länder, wo man so was überlebt hat und gesehen haben, was wir mitgemacht haben und was ich fühle .... da will ich schon sein zu Haus in Palästina.
David Boder: Warum sagen Sie zu Hause in Palästina? Haben Sie dort Verwandte?
Jola Gross: Nein, ich habe nicht. Aber das ist doch mein Heim. Ich bin doch eine Jüdin.
David Boder: Und darum ist Palästina Ihr Heim?
Jola Gross: Ich denke doch (lacht etwas). Wo denn??
David Boder: Ja. Sagen Sie mir zu wem sind Sie nach Paris gekommen? Nun ja, Sie ...
Jola Gross: Ich bin ...
David Boder: Hat man Sie nach Frankreich reingelassen?
Jola Gross: Ja. .
David Boder: Wie?
Jola Gross: Ja, illegal.
David Boder: Illegal. Wie sind Sie gekommen über die Grenze?
Jola Gross: Nun schwer. Ich bin durch. Ich habe die Grenze ....
David Boder: Von wo? Von Deutschland oder von ....
Jola Gross: Von Deutschland.
David Boder: Von Deutschland sind Sie reingekommen nach ...
Jola Gross: .... nach Frankreich.
David Boder: Und dann? Wie sind Sie gekommen nach Paris?
Jola Gross: In Paris bin ich hier in ..... im Heim, hm, von den.... hm, von die, wie heißt das schon, von den .....
David Boder: Wie heißt das Heim? Was ist das? Wo ....
Jola Gross: Das ist .....
David Boder: Das jüdische Komitee?
Jola Gross: Das jüdische Komitee, ja.
David Boder: Und was tun Sie hier den ganzen Tag?
Jola Gross: Was?
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: Ich arbeit .... ich muss doch all .... ich kann doch nähen.
David Boder: Sie können nähen?
Jola Gross: Nähen, ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Jola Gross: Arbeiten bis ich nach Palästina heraus fahre.
David Boder: Sie können nähen.
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Meinen Sie, Sie verdienen etwas Geld?
Jola Gross: Zur Zeit noch nicht.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Jola Gross: Ich hab keine Maschine ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: ... und noch keine Papiere — Aufenthaltspapiere. Bis ich das nicht schaffe dann ....
David Boder: Oh, so können Sie nicht arbeiten!
Jola Gross: Nein. Kann ich nicht arbeiten.
David Boder: Können Sie nicht ohne Aufenthaltspapiere privat ein bisschen arbeiten? Wenn Sie eine Maschine hätten könnten Sie selbst ein bisschen arbeiten?
Jola Gross: Ja, ich habe aber keine Maschine noch.
David Boder: Ja. Und mit der Hand, glauben Sie können Sie nicht viel nähen?
Jola Gross: Das geht nicht so.
David Boder: Es geht nicht!
Jola Gross: Man muss das präzise machen, wenn man will verdienen Geld. (lacht etwas)
David Boder: Ja, sagen Sie mir - zu Hause — wie gross war Ihre Familie?
Jola Gross: Wir sind zwölf (12) von der Familie nach Auschwitz gegangen. Wir sind zwei (2) zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Wer ist der Zweite?
Jola Gross: Eine Schwester.
David Boder: Ist sie hier mit Ihnen in Paris?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Oh, sind Sie mit Ihrer Schwester gekommen?
David Boder: Also wer waren die Zwölf (12), die nach Auschwitz gegangen sind?
Jola Gross: Die Zwölf war ein Bruder mit seinem Weib und ....
David Boder: Ja?
Jola Gross: .... und ein Sohn.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: Eine Schwester mit einem Schwager und zwei (2) Kindern, eine fünfzehn (15) jährige und eine dreizehn (13) jährige Tochter und eine Schwester mit einem Mann und einem Bruder.
David Boder: Und alle sind nach Auschwitz gegangen?
Jola Gross: Alle nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Und wie viele von denen hat man sofort auf die linke ... auf die rechte Seite gestellt?
Jola Gross: Wie viel? Wir ... ha .... no da sind drei (3) davon auf die rechte Seite (flüstert).
David Boder: Drei nach rechts
Jola Gross: Neun sind gleich ... in das Feuer (flüstert).
David Boder: Spreche Sie lauter. Neun sind was?
Jola Gross: Neun sind gleich ins Feuer.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer waren die Drei (3), die rausgekommen sind?
Jola Gross: Die Schwester in Birkenau.... ich... ich mit meiner Schwester und Bruder ....
David Boder: Oh, ja!
Jola Gross: ... das ist der, der dort hat gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und sind Sie mir Ihrer Schwester die ganze Zeit zusammen gewesen?
Jola Gross: Nein, nein. Die Schwester war extra.
David Boder: Und wo war die?
Jola Gross: Die Schwester war gleich nach Deutschland verschickt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: ... zur Arbeit.
Jola Gross: Und ich bin geblieben in Deutschland, in Birkenau zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja. So und wo haben Sie Ihre Schwester gefunden?
Jola Gross: In Budapest hab ich sie gefunden.
David Boder: Warum sind Sie nach Budapest gegangen?
Jola Gross: Ich bin sie gegangen suchen ...
David Boder: Aha!
Jola Gross: nachdem ich frei war.
David Boder: Und sagen Sie mir, nachdem man Sie befreit hat, wohin sind Sie gegangen? Zurück nach ....
Jola Gross: Ich bin ..... ich war in Deutschland und bin gefahren die Schwester suchen; ich war in, in Prag und bin jetzt gefahren nach Budapest. In Budapest hab ich sie gefunden. Dann sind wir zurück nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Ja, haben Sie gewusst, dass sie nach Budapest gegangen ist? Oder?
Jola Gross: Nein, ich habe sie zufälligerweise ....
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, wir haben Sie Ihre Schwester gefunden?
Jola Gross: Ich bin nach Budapest gekommen und da bin ich zum jüdischen Komitee hinein. Und dort bin ich gesessen sehr verzweifelt — ich bin allein und .... und sehr Viele sind gekommen, um zu fragen. Und ich hab nicht gewusst, wo sie ist.
David Boder: Ja, ah hm.
Jola Gross: Und dann kommt eine Bekannte und sagt: „Du bist hier! Deine Schwester ist vom Freitag an bei uns!” Sie ist Freitag gekommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Jola Gross: Sie war frei .... so haben sie sich am anderen Tag (unverständlich).
David Boder: Gesehen?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Getroffen?
Jola Gross: Getroffen
David Boder: Und dann haben Sie beschlossen?
Jola Gross: Dass wir gehen zurück. Dass wir müssen nach Deutschland ... und nach Palästina zu fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Jola Gross: .. wir wollen beide!
David Boder: Ist Ihre Schwester älter oder jünger?
Jola Gross: Älter.
David Boder: War sie verheiratet bevor?
Jola Gross: Nein.
David Boder: Nein. Also Ihr zwei ....
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: ....Sie sind zwei ....
David Boder: ......unverheiratete Mädchen?
Jola Gross: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie sich eingeschrieben für Palästina?
David Boder: Und hat man Ihnen versprochen, das Sie rüber gehen könne?
Jola Gross: Ja. Nur jetzt ist alles nicht so ..... in Ordnung, das ist nicht so leicht mit der Reise (oder Einreise) nach Palästina. Ich bleibe hier, aber ich will nach Palästina.
David Boder: So.
Jola Gross: Ich kann nicht mehr bleiben auf dem Boden, wo so was passiert ist und was ich gesehen habe.
David Boder: Nun, Fräulein Gross, ich danke Ihnen sehr. Das war aber eine sehr klare und gute Geschichte. Wie sagen Sie ist erster Name wieder?
Jola Gross: Jola.
David Boder: Wie schreiben Sie Ihren ersten Namen?
Jola Gross: Jola. J ...
David Boder: Schreiben Sie mir es auf, bitte. (Pause)
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the record of Miss Jola Gross of the age of thirty six (36). Hm, the record was taken on August 3rd at the Home for, hm, Adult Jews. And as we heard her, her intentions — her definite intentions — are to go home, which means to Palestine. She has some relatives in the United States, hm, but she does not know their addresses, doesn’t know about it.